[Musique]
et pour terminer ce journal on fait le
point sur les résultats sportifs du
week-end dans les yvelines avec michael
et demi d'euros bonsoir on sait rigoler
analystes aux sports de la rédaction de
tv 78 du handball pour commencer michael
avec le championnat honneur régional
trappe pg c'est l affiche de cette 14e
journée du championnat honneur régional
ce samedi 1er février dans une salle
bouillante chauffée par des centaines de
supporters les trappistes entre dans la
partie de la meilleure des façons en
prenant le large rapidement le score à
la pause 18 8
on y croit parce qu'on a mis beaucoup
d'intensité beaucoup beaucoup de rythme
[Musique]
on a réussi à monter les balles poser
nojy les attaques construit de la
patience on a récité notre meilleur
handball cette première mi temps
largement au retour des vestiaires les
trappistes reste devant mais connaissent
un passage à vide après la blessure d'un
joueur de l'équipe 15 minutes
d'interruption au total psg tente de
revenir après ce fait de jeu mais n'y
arrivera finalement pas ce qu'en finale
33 à 25 mai les trappistes dans ce match
accroché
rex il était compliqué c'est vrai
contre une équipe comme du passé qui a
été pratiquée était libre etc et reste
libre était qu'à l'habitude de jouer des
matches difficiles sont d'ailleurs
partis la semaine dernière ils étaient
préparés ils ont battu l'équipe tt
première ex-aequo avec nous et du coup
c'était un match compliqué à aborder à
préparer et mais on a réussi quand même
à rester
régulier et constant financement thouars
au classement trappe reste leader avec
deux points d'avancé sur val d'europe
prochain match pour les attrape east le
samedi 29 février sur le terrain de
montfermeil quatrième du classement une
victoire permettrait à trappes
d'envisager une sixième montée
consécutive en cinq ans on continue par
du football en football ont joué dans le
championnat de première division de
district voisin fait match nul contre
gargenville un partout le chenil
s'incline contre hardricourt 3-0 mort
parce s'offre un festival offensif
contre sartrouville 6 un match nul entre
auberge en ville et y 3 partout khariaga
ions s'offrent bois d'arcy 3 0 enfin à
bailly noisy gagne contre le pec 5 à 0
le championnat est dominé par maurepas
devant un gars gentil on termine par du
football mais cette fois-ci américain de
super bowl pour les tant pis mais un
match de championnat de deuxième
division casque d'or les élans courtois
se sont imposés 23 à 13 contre les
myrmidon de savigny-le-temple au
classement ce résultat permet aux
templiers de se replacer la troisième
place de leur poule après deux matches
disputés et une défaite lors de leur
premier match est ainsi mickaël plus de
résultats à suivre dans un instant votre
émission le cetud sport